I think I was gonna say I think another
thing that you probably I think that we
have to stop romanticizing the wrong
[ __ ] yeah like if you come from a
certain area
like at the end of the day unless you
own that real estate Shame about nothing
it ain't about nothing yo man who cares
like like who like I I one of my biggest
pet peeves is when I see people like I'm
still here y'all can't come over here
and I'm like yo like at the end of the
day like you grew up there and and and
you know where you grew up like your
goal should be to try to evolve and get
into a different situation here so we
can own this [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying involve and show you this and
that's crazy you saying that bro this
like
some of the deepest [ __ ] I've been
talking about right now with you because
I just did the AZ on the Block ship in
Chicago right there I just did the AZ on
the Block interview I thought about I'm
like I'm gonna go back to the block and
shoot this [ __ ] I thought like oh on
that [ __ ] gang I own a school in Chicago
I'm gonna shoot my [ __ ] right here
you're on the school I own the school
why would you shoot on the blocks at the
school that's what I'm gonna shoot right
here
right here in my [ __ ] I own this
property gang
I own this [ __ ] bro why not want to
shoot right here why not want to shoot
right here why not go back to the block
when I could own this [ __ ] and get this
[ __ ] to people who I care about how my
home and you got a uh a development
company a construction company a
painting company of real estate
management company get that [ __ ] to
y'all and now we really on the Block
post up on that [ __ ] all y'all want
let's do this that's what I'm on also
like your goal should always be to get
back to your kids every day hell yeah
and if it's like a three percent chance
to something wrong happens when you go
shoot that if it's a two percent chance
it's almost one percent chance don't do
it let me minimize I need to maximize
the chance of me getting home to my kids
all this chance [ __ ] I'm up suing some
[ __ ] rub me the wrong way I ain't doing
it you know what I'm saying but I was
the same [ __ ] like I know for a fact I
know every risk of doing this I'ma still
do it right because I feel like all
right but I could do it yeah because I
got that same like my my man how I work
I know I feel like I could overcome any
situation and that's dangerous so I'll
put myself and it's [ __ ] up situation
whatever happens I got it [ __ ] it we got
it until you don't until you don't
everything all good till it ain't until
it ain't nobody's bulletproof nobody is
uh everything all good until it ain't
bro nah that's some real [ __ ] and I
think a lot of people need to stop
moving around with um
just like I feel like false privilege
like hey man you ain't no better than
anybody else you know what I'm saying
and I know that though I understand that
if I'm saying I just feel like I was the
best version of myself right
that ain't no way to think